-Finally, it is Monday.
It is time for WeTweet.
Here go, everybody
-♪ WeTweet ♪
♪ WeTweet ♪
-Welcome to WeTweet.
This is where we, as a group,
decide something
that we should post on Twitter.
I'm gonna show you a series
a different tweets,
and we're gonna vote on whether
you like each one or not.
Y'all have voting clickers
at your seat.
You can vote for all of them,
you can vote for none of them.
Whatever you want to do.
We'll see the results live
on the screen here.
Higgins, Roots, you have
your clickers?
-Got it.
-Alright, good.
Whatever tweet gets
the most likes
we're gonna tweet it out
live on the show
so that you can all like it
and "we" tweet it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's a shared experience.
Alright, you guys ready
for this?
[ Cheers and applause ]
First tweet is...
[ Laughter ]
It's like, ooh.
Ah, that's...
Mmm, I like that.
I'll bag of those.
That's fantastic.
A half a chip?
I couldn't do anymore.
Perfect. Love it.
The votes are in,
let's see the results here.
Alright, half of you,
50/50.
Half, half people liked it,
half people did not enjoy.
-I'm three.
-No, yeah.
Alright, how about
this next one here?
Says...
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Feels like the crowd
voted already.
They just kind of all just...
-They voted with their laughs.
-I -- yeah, I feel like they're
all just kind of
voting, like,
not even animated.
You can move your hands.
You can...
[ Laughter ]
I don't want you
to get up and dance,
but yeah, you can do stuff.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, here we go, yeah.
People are dancing
to the music there.
I still say this is probably
50/50 again.
-Yeah, I think so.
-Let's see the results
on this one.
Alright, a little bit better.
Alright.
[ Cheers and applause ]
A little reminder, they don't
necessarily get better.
[ Laughter ]
Alright, next one says...
It's a beautiful thing.
-Come on.
-Yeah, look at that.
It's a party.
-Bring it up.
-That's what I'm talking about.
It's a party tonight.
Alright, let's see
the results here.
What do we think?
-Whoa!
-Wow.
Whoa!
-Hard to top.
174.
-It was at 174.
That's pretty big.
-It's pretty hard to top.
I think that might be the one,
but let's check
this one out here.
Next up...
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Not scared, I'm not scared.
-Not scared, not scared,
not scared.
This thing a little --
People are dancing.
[ Laughter ]
I love that.
Alright, good.
Let's see the results here.
This one feels pretty good.
No? Alright.
-Oh.
-Still good, but just not
as good as the other one.
-Wow.
-Yeah.
I think it's going
to be the other one.
-Yeah.
-Let's see.
We have one more.
It's the last one here.
This one's pretty good.
-Okay.
-Really?
-Yeah, I'm ready for it.
-What was the other one? What
was the other that we all liked?
-Paper cut.
-Circle of life.
-I don't know if this one's
gonna top paper cut.
-Really?
-This one's pretty good though,
but paper cut...
-Yeah, come one.
-Alright, here we go.
Last one.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on, we can do it!
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Come on, get the kids,
hold hands.
Let's go!
I feel good about this one.
-I feel good.
-I think it's gonna top 174.
-I think so.
-You think so?
Let's see the results.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow!
-Whoa! Wow!
That's the record, record.
I love you guys.
That is our winner right there.
194.
-Oh, my God.
-That is a record. I love
when a post hits right here.
During the commercial break,
if you see it on your feed,
give it a like,
give it a "we" tweet.